foreign
[Music]
ass pass
pass
[Music]
Full Pass
[Applause]
I don't want to see what's coming
pass
[Music]
pass pass
what
pass
pass oh
smash
pass
[Music]
what are you doing
that's awful
oh pass pass
[Music]
laughs
slope
yeah yeah pass
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah no no pass
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
I dare I see what would you take it even
further Beyond
[Music]
see I was gonna say smash I'll pass
yeah I'll pass
[Applause]
wow
all right pass
[Music]
[Laughter]
pass pass
[Music]
it gets stuck it gets stuck I don't
think I'm gonna get anywhere by getting
here I gotta go based off of like what
I've
said was smashed before
was our box match
it's better than matpat ever could
why do I have no idea
I have no idea I don't remember any of
these
I don't remember how am I supposed to
remember any of them
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh no what happened to you okay
[Music]
smash oh
pass this is oh man
oh pass
[Music]
oh no Bass
oh no
oh no no
oh no pass
no no no
ass
[Laughter]
oh
remember this will make it better
[Music]
[Applause]
pass pass
[Music]
pass
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
pass pass
pass
pass wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
all right smash all right all right
still it's Lucario
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah all right
yeah that is the X uh Cario after if we
this one's a pass but that was that's
obvious
I feel like for cardio is a bit of a
giveaway so if I say
[Music]
um
like it's been slim pickings I just
look I did
smash
foreign
[Music]
oh
pass
the highest pass
what are you
[Music]
ass
thank you
[Music]
oh boy
the pass but I'm gonna
pass I don't know why Lucario is the the
only one
all right
don't look at me like I'm crazy smash
right right
what happened
I don't know what happened okay
um pass
it's a close pass
I don't know why this button has never
made anything better so I don't know
what I'm expecting
thank you
uh-huh
[Music]
pass pass
I
know
oh God
[Music]
smash
oh
and smash
smash yeah
is that smash yeah smash
[Music]
yes match
ah pass smash
all right smash
up pass
[Music]
that's uh all right
pass yeah
[Music]
no I thought that was oh
oh my God
smash yeah oh sorry yeah
[Applause]
it's a bottle of sand it's a
it's
a pile of sand wow
[Laughter]
oh man smash yeah smash that's right all
right
um
no questions your honor I am leaving
have a good day
bye
foreign